j'en ai rien à [__] je m'en bats les
couilles voilà tout ce que je veux c'est
ton gros tu as compris ça je reste poli
il avait fait une vidéo où il avait
commencé à faire des tours dans sa ville
en regardant
pas dans une autre ville
moi je viendrai je vais venir je
t'assure que je vais venir regarder
ce que je te dis d'accord
un couteau dans une vidéo au revoir
parce que je veux vraiment qu'on voit ça
parce que c'est je veux vraiment que les
gens se mettent dans la peau aussi de ce
que ce qu'on veut les les juges aussi
donc regardez
je me sautais à mon adresse apparemment
elle va c'est quoi regarde regarde 50 kg
mais moi je me barre pas bien juste
Prométhée c'est simple je le plante sa
grand-mère maintenant attends juste que
tu reviennes le Corse on va voir j'ai
peur personne
de mes parents même si tu veux viens
qu'aujourd'hui aussi mais viens
maintenant tu sais où j'habite viens
pourquoi
l'impossibilité de lui attribuer les
messages avec certitude c'est s'agit oui
alors là sur ce jugement là il était
jugé pour menace de mort et ça vient
après les audio c'est notamment pour des
messages Instagram donc quand il a été
incarcéré pour cette affaire il avait
été en garde à vue lui la nier et les
enquêteurs les experts en
cybercriminalité ont saisi chez lui
ordinateur téléphone et ils n'ont pas pu
déterminer que les messages provenaient
de ces ordinateurs et de ses téléphones
donc ils l'ont relaxé il a été tensé par
la présidente du tribunal qui lui a
demandé de vous oublier de quitter les
réseaux sociaux elle lui a dit vous êtes
sur nos radars mais à la surprise
générale il a obtenu une relax parce
qu'effectivement on n'est pas sûr comme
les messages venaient du Maroc on n'est
pas sûr que c'est lui qui est l'auteur
de ces messages
il est allé alors il a déjà eu trois
condamnations il a cinq mentions à son
casier judiciaire dont trois liens vous
c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà
toujours passé mais sur ces faits là la
présidente un peu à son corps défendant
parce qu'on son dernier message qu'elle
est ennuyée elle dit on vous oubliera
pas
les faits c'est le doute lui profite et
donc il est relaxé quoi c'est une
surprise donc toi tu pensais être
tranquille Lucie
toujours pas non
je n'ai pas été condamné je peux
comprendre vu qu'il y a le doute mais ce
que je comprends pas c'est que avant
déjà il est il a essayé de rentrer chez
moi il a été relaxé il a des obligations
donc de pas rentrer en contact avec moi
de pas venir dans mon département et il
a essayé de rentrer chez moi du coup il
a été relaxé et ensuite il y a eu une
autre plante que j'ai déposée parce
qu'il est rentré directement en contact
avec moi en voyant en envoyant un
message d'excuse parce que ça avait
commencé à être médiatisé et malgré
qu'il m'a qui m'a envoyé un message donc
il est rentré en contact avec moi alors
qu'il n'a pas le droit il n'y a pas eu
de poursuite pour ça il a été relaxé
aussi pour ça donc c'est ça que je
comprends pas en fait et je me demande
combien de fois il peut récidiver ça va
être condamné
Gilles puisque elle comprend Lucie voilà
le truc impossibilité lui attribuer les
messages avec certitude mais il y a
d'autres faits puisqu'il pouvait pas
vous approcher déjà il est allé chez
elle et il a continué à la harceler
pourquoi il est pas condamné pour ça
parce que ça défense a été excellente il
dit je vais à son domicile ce jour-là
j'étais alcoolisé j'ai été maladroit
c'est une erreur il envoie un message de
son téléphone alors qu'il n'a pas le
droit de vous contacter toujours en
marche et là il dit oui il y avait
beaucoup de choses sur les réseaux
sociaux donc j'ai voulu écrire etc et
donc la la son avocate
je vais le dire brillamment évitez une
incarcération parce qu'elle a réussi à
prouver que finalement ces messages
étaient un tout petit peu anecdotique et
que sur les messages Instagram c'était
possiblement pas lui donc voilà c'est
vrai que c'est une immense surprise et
sur le fond peut vraiment débattre parce
que vous avez huit fois porter plainte
contre lui et aujourd'hui c'est vous la
victime qui est en insécurité c'est ça
qu'on ne comprend pas parce que les
enquêteurs essayent de prouver et de
remonter parce qu'il aurait peut-être pu
utiliser éventuellement ce qu'on appelle
un VPN pour mettre que l'adresse
IP soit pas la bonne etc transférer au
Maroc mais il n'arrive pas à voir la
preuve formelle à partir du moment où il
y a pas la preuve formelle et ben ils
sont dans l'incapacité de
ces excuses enfin il a fait en quelque
sorte un monde honorable ça n'a
absolument pas convaincu le le tribunal
et les experts ont déterminé quand même
un manque d'empathie perversité
personnalité manipulatrice et
on va avoir une autre vidéo vous vouliez
le bloquer sur les réseaux sociaux à
chaque fois ils vous envoyez ce genre de
menace regardez
j'étais gentil je sais pas si tu vas pro
tu m'as bloqué par mail je t'ai envoyé
plein de mails gentils tu veux m'ignorer
je vais faire la meuf il y a pas de
souci je suis calme d'habitude je suis
super calme mais tu me fous les nerfs
parce que tu te fous de ma gueule là
devant tes live de mon front de ma
taille de tout le vert mais ouais je
suis petit ce mec c'est ce que tu veux
mais je m'attaquerai ta famille
m'attaquerai ta famille tu sais pas à
quel point tu m'énerves ça a très mal
finir pour nous tous nous tous on dit
quoi là
c'était pas l'objet du process c'est ça
le problème Cyril c'est qu'on a pas jugé
la globalité ça a été jugé de manière
éparse et je vous comprends tout à fait
le site parce que vous aujourd'hui vous
vous dites mais tout repart à zéro le
voilà de nouveau libre et peut-être de
nouveau entre guillemets libres de voir
ce lait de nouveau bah c'est ça que je
comprends pas c'est qu'en fait j'ai
porté plainte aussi pour le fait qu'il
soit rentré en contact avec moi et qu'il
a pas le droit et pour ça il a été
relaxé et pour le fait que soit venu
chez moi j'ai aussi porter plainte et ça
aussi il a été relaxé il y a que cette
peine là où je peux comprendre mais le
reste je ne comprends pas comment ils
expliquent qu'ils soient venus chez elle
et qu'il soit relaxé c'est ça qui est à
lui il a
ivre alcoolisé je ne me rendais pas
compte c'est une erreur
des responsabiliser de ça je vous dis
pas que c'est légitime
il a réussi à dire finalement je n'étais
pas dans mon état normal et ce n'est pas
moi qui suis allé mais moi j'avais pris
il est pris un avocat commis d'office ou
bien séduit qui avait choisi son avocat
non je crois que c'est un avocat Cyril
je crois que c'est une avocat il y a du
bon ah oui donc c'est une avocate
il a pu trouver les fonds pour payer
l'avocate je crois je suis pas formel
mais je crois et on peut rappeler que
Lucile nous avait dit qu'il était enfin
sa famille était dans dans la police
c'est ça j'ai pas le droit de en parler
parce qu'il y a une affaire dessus
d'accord donc c'est pareil on l'a on a
aimé cette hypothèse et elle ne nous a
jamais été confirmée ni par Lucile ni
par son avocate et donc nous ne sommes
pas sûr qu'il bénéficient d'une
protection et en tout cas selon le
jugement qui a été rendu ici ça n'a pas
interféré c'est vraiment l'absence de
responsabilité directe qui a joué mais
est-ce que sur ce coup là en fait la
juge la mise en garde en cas de récidive
est-ce que s'il recommence là pour le
coup il risque cette fois-ci est-ce que
ce sera la fois de trop est-ce qu'il y a
eu une injonction pas du tout oui ils
l'ont mis un rappel à la loi sauf qu'en
fait à chaque fois il a un rappel à la
loi donc ça fait beaucoup de rappel pour
pas de changement en fait à chaque fois
il recommence donc
déménagé plusieurs fois vous allez
porter plainte plusieurs fois rien n'y
fait harceleur a fait plusieurs
allers-retours en prison il n'a jamais
purgé la totalité de ses peines il s'en
vente d'ailleurs
en juillet j'étais condamné à la prison
ferme mais regarde où je suis je suis
libre comme l'air je fais ce que je veux
il y a toujours un moyen de moi je veux
toujours me démerder sauf que la même si
j'arrive je te vois je t'ai gorge je te
viole je sais que je prendrai jamais 20
ans
et donc et c'est vrai que c'est grave à
dire parce que moi de ce dont j'ai peur
dans cette histoire vraiment que ça se
termine mal ah oui on dirait un moment
tu dis qu'est-ce que c'est ça le
problème mais on attend qu'il y a un
drame malheureusement c'est ça
aujourd'hui un drame du code d'un côté
ou non et d'un côté ou de l'autre parce
que ça on est voilà on espère pas qu'il
va y avoir mais ça peut être un drame
pour Lucie ou bien on sait jamais
imaginons que voilà un moment voilà et
Lucile il y a des gens qui qui
interviennent et que voilà et que ça si
demain lui ça se passe mal pour lui
derrière c'est sur les réseaux sociaux
ça défense elle est lunaires pardon sur
les réseaux
il y a un accident pour lui aussi voilà
oui mais je vais demander Lucie
justement s'il y avait une expertise
psychiatrique pour savoir évaluer sa
réelle dangerosité ou pas oui on a une
mais apparemment il a aucun trouble
mental aucune maladie mentale il a il
aurait juste des problèmes de
frustration et du mal à accepter le fait
qu'on lui dise non
pas de pathologie psychiatrique
colérique et comme je disais pervers
manipulateur tu dis quoi de la décision
Lucie la décision déjà la première
décision sur le fait qu'il soit allé
chez moi je trouve que c'est ridicule de
lui avoir rien mis parce que il était
alcoolisé dans ce cas-là tout le monde
peut être alcoolisé dehors et faire
n'importe quoi sans rien avoir en
sachant qu'il a des obligations et qui
respectent rien enfin moi j'arrive pas à
comprendre ton histoire de je suis
alcool vidéo
et se contentent de dire ah bah oui il
avait bu un verre de trop euh
tu peux bourrer la gueule tu peux faire
n'importe quoi et sous prétexte que tu
as vu tu peux harceler quelqu'un
agresser quelqu'un et c'est OK
vivre dans la peur alors que vous êtes
une victime et c'est terrible pour tout
le monde parce que tous les harceleurs
potentiels qui voient cette décision ils
vont dire en fait je peux menacer de
mort je peux rentrer chez quelqu'un je
peux prendre un couteau mais j'aurais
presque rien mais c'est dramatique alors
il a été borné près de chez vous
oui c'est ça la police m'a appelé pour
me dire qu'il avait borné dans ma rue
apparemment le lendemain où je suis
rentrée de vacances il a borné dans ma
rue apparemment
est-ce que vous bénéficiez une
protection policière
la loi le jugement vous a dit qu'il a
pas le droit de venir devant chez vous
oui il a pas le droit d'aller au
domicile et c'est après que la police je
vous ai dit il a borné devant chez vous
oui pourquoi la police
obligation c'est pas dans la procédure
c'était avant qu'il soit jugé là mais ça
a pas été noté et vous allez faire quoi
bah déménager je pense sauf qu'en fait
sauf que là ce que je comprends pas
c'est qu'en fait j'ai donné mon adresse
à personne j'ai pas donné mon adresse
dans les papiers etc pour qu'elle
apparaisse nulle part parce que la
première fois il a eu mon adresse parce
qu'il les avait eu dans les papiers du
jugement là j'ai fait attention de pas
mettre mon adresse etc mais il a quand
même réussi à l'avoir donc je me demande
bah comment il fait et vous avez
déménagé donc on lui donne raison et là
encore une fois c'est quand même ils
disent quoi votre entourage vos parents
votre fiancé là
on voit plus de solutions en fait on
porte plainte il se passe rien malgré
que il ne respectent rien il a des
obligations de suivre une formation de
travailler etc il n'y va pas il a des
obligations de pas aller chez moi il ne
le fait pas de pas rentrer en contact
avec moi il le fait pas il continue à
harceler etc et il se passe rien donc en
fait on voit plus de solutions à part
peut-être déménager dans un autre pays
ou alors
tu as pas changé ta vie à cause d'un
problème c'est qu'en fait c'est moi qui
me retrouve en prison alors que c'est
lui qui est censé être et moi j'ai plus
de liberté je peux plus vivre
normalement est-ce que la police ou lui
ils ont réagi au fait que vous
médiatisez l'affaire parce que vous en
avez parlé beaucoup vous dans les
émissions etc ce qu'ils vous ont
reproché ça limite ce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il vous traite comme une
coupable presque moi je suis pas allé au
jugement parce que justement j'ai pas
envie qu'il me voit et qui se disent bah
que j'y suis allé peut-être parce que je
l'aime j'ai envie de le voir ou je sais
pas ce qui peut penser dans sa tête mais
j'ai pas eu de retour sur ça après je
sais que au jugement je crois qu'ils ont
dit que bon ils comprenait mon action
même si ça leur plaisait pas et
d'ailleurs le jugement aussi l'hypothèse
a été faite que peut-être que c'était
moi vu que je suis allé une fois au
Maroc qui m'a envoyé des messages à
moi-même pour porter plainte et vous
êtes jamais sorti ensemble il y a pas eu
d'histoire
on va rappeler l'histoire parce que
non à chaque fois en fait tu m'as raté
deux fois une fois il m'attendait
j'étais en retard et il a menacé mon ami
avec un couteau et du coup la deuxième
fois où il a voulu rentrer chez moi et
le gardien la surpris mais du coup la
troisième fois en fait
qu'est-ce qui va se passer soit il va
réussir un matin ou peut-être qu'il va
par miracle rater encore une fois mais
ce qui sera condamné je pense pas ce
qu'on rappelle au téléspectateurs cette
histoire c'est que tu ne le connais pas
du tout ça en fait comment c'est comment
déjà ça a commencé sur les réseaux il
m'avait envoyé un message et j'aimerais
recondu et après je lui ai plus répondu
et c'est jamais arrêté en fait c'est ça
je suis le 29 va se passer quoi
il a déjà été condamné à 8 mois fermes
il avait fait trois mois je vous
rappelle la phrase du procureur du
procès précédent Cyril très inquiétante
il va la poursuivre aussi longtemps
qu'il l'aura dans la peau donc ça la
justice a pris conscience de entre
guillemets ça dangerosité son obsession
pour vous et n'a pas pris conscience non
non mais pris conscience préalablement
mais aujourd'hui ne l'a pas condamné là
ce qu'on espère vraiment c'est qu'en fin
il va respecter la mesure d'éloignement
là là à l'heure qu'il est relaxer il est
relaxé donc plus rien plus rien donc là
c'est si il fait autre chose oui c'est
la phrase c'est la phrase de la juge là
on vous a sur nos radars c'est à dire
que à la prochaine là vous risquez
d'être condamné mais rien n'est sûr mais
rien n'est sûr
menacer il prend des mecs qui font du
bodybuilding il prend des costaud sur
les réseaux sociaux il les insultes il
leur donne rendez-vous dans des gares et
stop avec des vrais bonhommes il arrête
de faire chier les filles et il se
trouve un travail et il se trouve une
vie et essaie de faire je sais pas même
fonder une famille peut-être un miracle
on sait jamais mais qu'il arrête de
faire il arrête de faire bouffon comme
ça c'est bidon ce qu'il est en train de
faire et Lucile avec d'autres jeunes
femmes qui également ont été harcelées
quand il était mineur il a déjà été
condamné quand il était mineur ensuite
tu as eu des plans contre lui encore
maintenant et je crois qu'il avait été
condamné du coup en juillet 2021 parce
qu'il me le disait dans les audio mais
il parlait pas de moi donc il parlait
d'une autre fille je crois mais je sais
pas à quoi et il a dit qu'il avait été
condamné mais que il restait quand même
dehors il a il arrivait quand même à
rester dehors mais comment on arrive pas
à empêcher ces mecs là de nuire je
comprends pas pourquoi
vraiment c'est incroyable je sais pas ce
qu'on peut souhaiter pour l'instant moi
je te dis attends un peu avant de de
tout lâcher quitter le pays comment ça
serait dramatique que tu déménages
encore une fois franchement ça serait
vraiment un énorme échec pour pour
la société parce que je demande pour
nous parce que c'est incroyable Lucille
j'espère que ça va arrêter de t'embêter
pour l'instant tu as pas de news non
mais je pense qu'il m'enverra plus de
messages et qu'il attend juste d'agir
bah je l'ai bloqué partout mais en fait
maintenant il m'envoie plus de messages
et il fait comment pour votre compte
va travailler ça